the death toll from a religious cult in
Kenya has risen to at least 89 it is
expected to rise as rights groups have
registered more than 200 people as
missing authorities say the victims
starved themselves to death after their
Pastor Paul McKenzie told them to stop
eating if they wanted to meet Jesus
police have been exhuming bodies from
shallow graves in a forest on land that
McKenzie owns they say the site has been
classified as the scene of a massacre
Catherine soy is live from the town of
malindi Catherine I know you have been
at the scene where bodies are exhumed
death toll has kept going up over the
last few days is it expected to keep
Rising
well absolutely the death tone has been
going up every day and we've been
speaking to the police who are saying
like they expect to see more bodies now
uh the police are now in another area
what we were seeing
um Mass Graves that has been exhumed but
they have gone to another area in the
same uh area and they expect to see more
bodies so that is an operation that is
going on uh people are very shocked
about what uh is going on we have been
talking to the red Red Cross Red Cross
which who have set up
a tracing Center and they say that up to
200 people have been declared missing we
have spoken to some of their relatives
who are saying that they are just hoping
that their loved ones will be found safe
and alive
what are we finding out with the
investigation on this
we have been speaking to government
officials who have been visiting the
scene including
their Secretary of interior who has said
that basically
um what the police are trying to do is
to make sure that this man is charged
with terrorism it's going to be very uh
interesting to see if these charges will
stick uh he miss Mackenzie at this pasta
is very very well known here in malindi
about especially when it comes to his
controversial teaching he has been
taking he has been telling people not to
take children to school not to vaccinate
children as well so that is something
that a lot of people are asking about
you know questions that our people are
asking of why did this uh incident take
so long to be discovered we know that
post-promotem is going on
um the quality pathologies are trying to
know how these people died and so it's
an ongoing process it's going to be a
very long uh painful process as well
Catherine Catherine soy reporting from
malindi in Kenya thank you very much